Heute im Rasenfunk. Das ist ein Mädchen, ein unglaubliches Mädchen. Der Frankfurter schießt Eintracht Frankfurt in die Bundesliga.
Eckball, Langer fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Der S ist vor allem das A- und P-Team steht für attraktiv und preiswert in der Bundesliga. Und jetzt ist das letzte Kapitel im verrücktesten Fußballmärchen der Saison geschrieben.
Ach, ihr lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, diejenigen von euch, die das jetzt nur in Anführungszeichen hören und nicht bei YouTube sehen, euch entgehen immer die Reaktionen meiner Gäste auf dieses Intro. Das war schon beim letzten Mal sehr interessant. Und diesmal auch. Es changierte zwischen Begeisterung und Fassungslosigkeit. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk in der Ligatur in unserem Format, in dem wir auf andere Ligen blicken als eben die ersten Ligen bei den Männern und bei den Frauen. Dazu ist gestern eine Folge erschienen über die Copa Libertadores. Und heute natürlich, das ist ja dann quasi die deutsche Copa Libertadores, die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Über die wollen wir heute sprechen. Schön, dass ihr da seid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und auf Blue Sky. Und ich begrüße hier eine schöne Runde bei mir. Zum einen mit ihrem Rasenfunk-Debüt von der Sportshow unter anderem. Lisa Höfer, hallo Lisa, schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja hallo Max, hallo in die Runde, hallo nach draußen. Schön, dass es endlich geklappt hat. So lange darüber gesprochen und jetzt endlich, ich freue mich.
Ja, aber wirklich, ich weiß gar nicht, wann wir zum ersten Mal Kontakt hatten. Ich glaube vor 2 Jahren oder sowas, Minimum, wenn nicht sogar länger. Also schön, dass du hier bist. Du wirst uns was über den 1. FC Nürnberg erzählen. Und dann konnte ich es mir natürlich nicht verkneifen, dann noch jemanden von der Spielvereinigung einzuladen. Michael Fischer ist mal wieder hier. Den kennt ihr natürlich schon, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hallo Michael, schön, dass du da bist. Ja, das werden wir gleich noch thematisieren, wie eng da so manches zusammengerückt ist. Der Einzige, der ein bisschen abrückt, aber nur dessen Verein. Natürlich nicht, der Gast ist Jörn Kreuzer, der auch hier ist. Hallo Jörn, schön, dass du da bist. Ja, ja, ja, ich bin mal gespannt. Jörn, bei dir wird sowieso das Interessante, wie beim letzten KST Schwerpunkt auch schon, wie viel Sportliches wird stattfinden. Reichen wir das Prozent oder wird es noch weniger? Aber gut, wir werden es sehen. Bevor wir loslegen, noch einen Hinweis oder zwei Hinweise, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Zum einen, wenn ihr das hier noch rechtzeitig hört, am Dienstag, den 14. November werde ich in München meine dies für dieses Jahr letzte Lesungen abhalten. Also ich werde was von Uli Hoeneß erzählen und aus meinem Buch lesen. Im Stadion an der Schleißheimer Straße könnt ihr noch Plätze reservieren. Ein paar sind noch da und aber viel wichtiger der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbungsponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de supportersclub erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Jeder Euro hilft. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns schon unterstützt haben. Oder vielleicht jetzt kurz auf Stop drücken und das machen. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Danke für euren Support. Dann lasst uns doch mal blicken auf diese 2. Liga. 12 Spieltage sind gespielt und wenn wir mal auf den letzten Spieltag zurückblicken. Lisa, was war denn das, was man dazu unbedingt wissen muss? Was ist denn so bemerkenswert? Das passiert deiner Meinung nach.
Ich habe ja gerade im Vorgespräch schon so ein bisschen gestanden, wenn ich nicht arbeiten muss, wie letztes Wochenende, dann gucke ich natürlich immer Einzelspiel und den Club und kriege dann den Rest so semi mit. Aber ich glaube, was jeder mitbekommen hat und was gar nicht nur sportlich relevant war, nämlich eigentlich gar nicht relevant, die Choreo. Nürnberg, Schalke, also das war mein Highlight des Spiels. Das ist taurig, aber wahr, das war wirklich für mich schon vor Anpfiff der Moment. Ich glaube, das sind so Bilder, die wünscht man sich als Fan eigentlich immer zu sehen und das hat großen Spaß gemacht. Ganz generell glaube ich, 2. Liga gerade so geil wie selten. Über die Tabelle hast du ja schon ein bisschen geteased gerade. Das wird immer enger, das wird immer spannender. Tatsächlich, St. Pauli macht mir auch großen Spaß im Moment. Eigentlich gar keinen Bezug zu dem Club, aber da guckt man irgendwie gerne zu im Moment, finde ich. Aber die Choreo war tatsächlich mein Highlight des Spieltags, auch wenn es mit dem Spiel nichts zu tun hatte.
Was war denn so besonders an der Choreo? Es tut mir leid, stehen zu müssen, ich habe sie nicht gesehen.
Also sie ging von der Nordkurve bis über die Gegendrade bis zum Auswärtsblock. Also um das halbe Max-Morlock-Stadion war natürlich wieder so eine gemeinschaftliche Choreo zwischen den Schalkern und den Klubberern. Es gab extra Fanshals, die man auch nur am Stadion kaufen konnte. Die Choreo war im Endeffekt auch ein großer Fanschal. Also man musste es gesehen haben. Ich bin geschockt, Max, dass du es nicht gesehen hast. Auch nicht auf Social Media oder so. Es war doch überall. Also wenn man es mal nicht gesehen hat, würde ich sagen, einmal kurz googeln. War schon erste Liga, würde ich sagen.
Ich bin gerade so eben mit dabei. Ich war privat sehr eingeschwannter an diesem. Ah, da ist sie doch. Ja, das ist doch tatsächlich nicht so schlecht. Ein Bündnis für die Ewigkeit. Ja, das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht. Das ist doch mal die Art von Freundschaftsschal, die man gerade noch so übertragen kann. Über 60 Meter über ein komplettes Stadion. Michi, ich nehme an, die Choreo vom Klub war auch eines deiner Highlights. Aber gab es darüber hinaus noch welche?
Also, ich habe sie nicht gesehen, weil ich gleichzeitig in Kaiserslautern war.
Aber die muss man doch gesehen haben, Michi.
Im Nachhinein habe ich sie natürlich gesehen. Natürlich. Ich war in Kaiserslautern. Und in Kaiserslautern hat das Klip-Lad ein Auswärtsspiel gewonnen. Man kann es kaum glauben. Zum ersten Mal in dieser Saison. Und zum ersten Mal seit dem Ostersonntag haben sie wieder ein Auswärtsspiel gewonnen. Unerklärlich. Es kann niemand erklären. Ich habe das schon sehr viele Menschen in Fürth gefragt. Den wechselnden Trainer ja auch schon in der letzten Zeit. Über die letzten Jahre auch. Fürth gewinnt fast nie Auswärtsspiele. In der vergangenen Saison waren sie ja letztes Jahr in der Auswärtstabelle. Da haben wir im Sommer darüber gesprochen. In der Recap der letzten Saison. Und jetzt waren sie wieder auf Platz 16 der Auswärtstabelle. Mit nur zwei Punkten aus fünf Spielen. Waren unter der Woche. Und auch zur Wahrheit im Pokal in Homburg beim vermeintlich schwächsten Gegner. Auch ausgeschieden nach regulärer Spielzeit 1 zu 2. Und dann gewinnt sie einfach 2-0 beim FCK. Der so heimstark ist, dass er in der Heimtabelle auch auf Platz 4 war. Also ich bin immer noch ein bisschen sprachlos, wie vielleicht man hier merkt. Ich kann es mir ganz gern erklären. Aber es war ein extrem gutes Auswärtsspiel der Spielvereinigung. Und das habe ich jetzt noch nicht so oft gesehen in den letzten Jahren.
Bestimmt wurde da Alexander Zorninger und das ganze Team von kritischen Nachfragen, diverse Reporter, der nahm sich auf Tischereimen angestachelt. Anders kann es ja gar nicht sein, dass das möglich war.
Ekla.
Ekla, ekla. Jörn, hattest du noch ein Highlight an diesem Wochenende?
Zum einen bei unserem Heimspiel war ja kurz nach dem 30-jährigen Jubiläum von Valencia. Das Spiel stand ganz unter dem Motto. Und es war ganz schön, dass die Mannschaft von damals im Stadion war. Auch Winni Schäfer und der Roland Schmieder, der Präsident, der enorm alt geworden ist, finde ich, aber immerhin mit einer wunderbaren 90er-Jahre-Krawatte reüssieren konnte. So hellblau mit so Fußbällen drauf. Und dann steht KSC dunkelblau drauf. Ein Traum. Ja, das Spiel war dann weniger schön. Und in Erinnerung blieben ja auch, wenn wir bei so optischen Dingen bleiben, der Freitagabend mit dem souveränen Auswärtssieg von Wiesbaden bei Düsseldorf mit einer Kombination aus neongelben Trikots und grauen Hosen. Unfassbar furchtbar, aber auch überraschendes Ergebnis. Und ich wohne ja hier in Hamburg, deshalb haben wir im kleinen Kreis mit den Kita-Eltern das Spiel von St. Pauli angeguckt. Was eine noch größere Überraschung war, wie dieses Nürnberg-Spiel vor ein paar Wochen beispielsweise, weil wir einfach einen souveränen Auswärtssieg beim Aufsteiger feiern. Wo in 90 Minuten nichts antrennt, sind alle hier nicht gewohnt.
Also Düsseldorf gegen Wiesbaden, endlich hat es mal jemand gesagt. Also eure Choreos und sonstigen Ereignisse, alles in Ehren. Aber das war ja das, was mich überrascht hat an diesem Wochenende. Düsseldorf zu Hause 1 zu 3 gegen Wiesbaden. Das war schon was Besonderes. Aber Jörn, jetzt muss ich noch einmal kurz nachhaken, natürlich höchst investigativ. Du hast uns im Vorgespräch gesagt, dass du seit 30 Jahren KSC-Fans bist. Bist du dann mit Euro-Eddie quasi zum KSC-Fan geworden? Oder anders gesagt, bist du einer von ganz wenigen Erfolgs-KSC-Fans?
Na, ich muss sagen, da fing es gewissermaßen schon an. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich das Spiel schauen durfte, ganz. Weil meine Cousine war damals im Stadion und ich habe irgendwie als 10-Jähriger versucht, sie zu entdecken. Hat nicht funktioniert.
Haben die die ganze Zeit nur Tore gezeigt, wie nervig.
Gewissermaßen. Und ich fand es auch letzte Woche ganz cool, da haben sie auf Instagram so eine Art Re-Life gemacht. Und ich finde es wahnsinn, dass Euro-Eddy auf dem Weg in die Kabine interviewt wurde, in der Halbzeit. Zum Beispiel. Also, die haben das auch alles mitgenommen. Das war eine andere Welt damals. Ich glaube sogar auf Sat.1.
Ja, Sat.1 waren auch die, die damit tatsächlich auch angefangen haben, mit den Interviews während des laufenden Spiels. Das habe ich ja in 11 Leben, glaube ich, auch verarbeitet. Das war ein 2-4 beim KSC. Da war Co-Kommentator, war Otto Rehagel, der total ausgerastet ist, weil da nämlich durch das vierte Tor von Karlsruhe seine Bremer, die Bayern überholt haben, an der Tabellenspitze standen. Das war der vorletzte Tabellenspieltag. Und er hat nur beim 4-0 gesagt, klasse, klasse, klasse. Wir haben das einfach nur gesehen. Also, da ging alles ab. Und dann wurde Erich Rübeck, Bayern-Trainer damals, noch während der laufenden zweiten Halbzeit von Stefan Hermanns interviewt. Der ihn dann, Thomas Hermanns, Entschuldigung, der ihn dann so Fragen gestellt hat wie, ja, nicht so gut, oder? Und Erich Rübeck, ja, was wollen Sie jetzt von mir, dass ich dazu sage, während des laufenden Spiels? Das waren Zeiten damals. Aber gut, jetzt haben wir nicht nur den letzten Spieltag, sondern auch das wunderbare, den wunderbaren Sieg gegen Valencia nochmal aufgearbeitet. Im Grunde ist unsere Pflicht getan. Aber jetzt gehen wir dann halt einfach schon mal zu Kür über. Wir wollen über eure drei Vereine sprechen. Und wie immer gibt die Tabelle die Reihenfolge vor. Und da ist es zwar sehr eng, denn wir haben insgesamt 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Teams, die 18 Punkte haben. Aber die beste Tordifferenz von diesen Teams hat das Kleeblatt, die Spielvereinigung aus Fürth. Und das wegen eines vollkommen erwarteten Auswärtssieges, wie wir es gerade schon gelernt haben. Michi, wie verläuft denn die Saison bisher? Du hast ja schon angedeutet, dass man zumindest auswärts, wie in der letzten Saison auch schon, ein Problem hat. Gleichzeitig die DFB-Pokal aus hast du auch schon angesprochen. Und vielleicht hat der eine oder andere die eine oder andere mitbekommen. Alexander Zorninger hat seinem Namen auch alle Ehre gemacht vor diesem Auswärtsspiel beim FCK. Was war denn da los schon wieder?
Puh, so viele Fragen auf einmal, Max. Wir fangen vielleicht ganz vorne an im Sommer. Weil wir haben ja, glaube ich, seit vielen Monaten nicht mehr über die Spielfahnen gesprochen an der Stelle. Man muss schon dazu sagen, wenn man so auch den Höhenflug des FCK der letzten Monate sieht, das sind zwei Spieler, die dann nicht unbeteiligt sind mit Tobi Raschl und Ragnar Ache, die in der vergangenen Saison noch in Fürth gespielt haben. Das gehört auch schon mal zur Wahrheit dazu, dass diese beiden spielen nicht mehr in Fürth. Ragnar Ache hätte Fürth zum Beispiel auch gerne gehabt. Sie werden ja angeblich bis zu 2 Millionen kolportiert. Als arme Kirchenmaus Fürth kann man das natürlich nicht bezahlen. Und Tobi Raschl wollte offenbar auch gehen. Das heißt, man hat da zwei Spieler verloren. Man hat aber Sebastian Grießbeck auch verloren, der jetzt in Braunschweig spielt. Übrigens zum letzten Spieltag noch, ich weiß, ob die Zahl auf allen Portalen stimmt, aber Braunschweig hatte 0,0 Expected Goals beim Derby in Hannover. Hab ich auch noch selten gesehen bislang. Da wird auch mal hier eine Statistik gedroppt, ist ja im Podcast. Da hat man auch noch Max Christensen verloren, war eine Posse an Hannover 96. Da ging es um verschiedene Verlängerungsoptionen, die nicht gezogen wurden, nur mündlich gezogen wurden. Also ich könnte so viele Geschichten aus Füttchen erzählen. Ja, und da hat man eben Marco John, war auch sehr wichtig im vergangenen Jahr, ein wichtiger Außenverteidiger, der nach Hoffenheim zurückgegangen ist dann. Und da jetzt aber nur in der Regionalliga im Mannschaftsspiel verletzt ist, also man hat eigentlich 5 fast Stammspieler verloren aus der vergangenen Saison, obwohl man eigentlich was aufbauen wollte mit Alexander Zorniger. Das heißt, man hat im Sommer eigentlich wieder neu angefangen, was Neues aufzubauen. Es lief eigentlich auch ziemlich gut. Man hat gegen den FC Liverpool gespielt. Und da wird sich Jörn auch erinnern, die haben ja so eine Deutschland-Tour gemacht beim KSC. Da haben sie vor Zuschauern gespielt. Gegen Fürth haben sie in Villingen-Schwenningen ohne Zuschauer gespielt, aber vor 200 Sponsoren und VIPs, die dann da waren, was gut ankam bei allen Menschen, die daheim bleiben durften. Ja, und da haben sie, hat Fürth 4 zu 4 gespielt gegen Liverpool. Also, ich zeig dir schon, die Offensive ist ganz gut, die Abwehr vielleicht nicht. Auch da kann man Achterbahn fahren, mal ist die Offensive gut, mal ist die Defensive gut. Und dann hat man am ersten Spieltag, wenn sich auch vielleicht viele erinnern, 5 zu 0 gewonnen gegen den SC Paderborn. Natürlich 83 Minuten lang ein Überzahl, aber trotzdem ein offensiv richtig starker Auftritt der Spielvereinigung. Ja, und dann hat man einfach zu den drei Spielen danach nur noch einen Punkt geholt und 5 zu 0 bei der Hertha verloren, 1 zu 3 gegen Hannover zu Hause verloren und ging dann eben mit 1 zu 8 Toren aus den beiden Spielen in die erste Länderspielpause. Und dann dachte man sich, okay, es geht einfach so weiter wie in der Anfang der Saison, wo man ja auch erst am 33. Spieltag den Klassen halt fix gemacht hat. Ja, und diese erste Länderspielpause ist vielleicht zu der ersten Meilenstelle noch dieser Saison, bei der man reden muss. Also weil, wer Alexander Zorniger kennt und ihm zuhört, ihm ist laufen und du magst gern die Laufstatistik natürlich auch. Die ist ihm besonders wichtig, er hat Sprints, intensive Läufe, insgesamt die Kilometer und offensichtlich hat er dann nochmal in dieser Länderspielpause mit allen Spielern Einzelgespräche geführt mit seinem Trainerteam und auch nochmal die Laufwerte der vergangenen Saison rekapituliert und den Spieler nahegelegt, was sie denn laufen müssten, wie viel sie sprinten müssten, wie viele intensive Runs, wie er immer sagt, sie haben müssten. Und das hat Wirkung gezeigt, da wird sich auch Lisa erinnern, das Derby in Nürnberg war nach der Länderspielpause das erste Spiel und es war ziemlich gut von der Spielvereinigung. Sie haben eigentlich 1-0 geführt, haben sogar erst 2-0 noch gemacht, stand zur Pause vermeintlich 2-0 und dann hat aber noch Can Uso, gar noch nicht genannt in diesem Podcast, geht eigentlich gar nicht. Es geht nicht ohne Can Uso in die 2.
Liga.
Ich weiß nicht, also heute nicht. Ja, man muss immer über Can Uso sprechen.
Richtig.
Das habe ich gelernt von meinen Kollegen, dass man immer über Can Uso sprechen muss, weil der ist eigentlich der nächste Messi.
Mindestens.
Das ist doch der, der ausgerutscht ist, oder?
Aber der hat einen, muss man schon sagen, als 17-Jährigen im Derby vor 50.000 Zuschauern den Elfmeter zum 1 zu 1 ganz locker, flockig mal reinzumachen. Aber das war schon gut und dann hat Fürth aus diesen Spielen danach auch wieder mehr Punkte geholt und insgesamt nur eins der letzten sieben Spiele verloren. Also offensichtlich hat diese noch mal diese Ansprache, dieses Reden über Zahlen, also auch Maxi Dietz, ein Spieler, bei dem vielleicht auch noch sprechen könnten bei der Spielverhandlung, den nicht viele kennen. Ein junger Spieler, der jetzt Stammspieler ist, kam letztes Jahr von der eigenen U23 nach oben. Und der hat auch gesagt, die Trainer haben uns einfach gesagt, wie viel mehr wir laufen müssen, sinngemäß. Und seitdem funktioniert es wieder. Und natürlich gibt es noch Spiele, in denen man nicht so gut ist. Also beim HSV hat man auch dann relativ klar verloren, 0 zu 2. Aber trotzdem hat man drei der letzten vier Spiele gewonnen. Vor der vergangenen Woche, vor dem Heimspiel gegen Osnabrück, war man 14. Jetzt hat man zwei Mal in Folge gewonnen. Jetzt ist man 6. Und am kommenden Wochenende spielt man gegen Düsseldorf. Und wenn Spielfang da gewinnt, der müsste sehr hoch gewinnen. Aber wenn sie 4-0 gewinnt, könnten sie 3. werden. Verrückte 2. Liga.
Verrückte 2. Liga, auch verrückt, wie netto gegenüber den Gästen bist. Das 1 zu 1 gegen den Klub, das musstest du ansprechen. Aber dass du es 4 zu 3 gegen den KSC einfach so übergangen hast, wo ja irgendwie in der Nachspielzeit der ersten Hälfte noch zwei oder drei Treffer gefallen sind, ich weiß es gerade gar nicht.
Tatsächlich hatte ich schon verdankt. Es passiert so viel in Fürth.
Aber du hast ja jetzt schon angesprochen, dass viele Abgänge zu kompensieren waren. Und du hast auch schon angesprochen, was sich quasi verändert hat in dieser magischen Länderspielpause. Es ist ja schön, dass man Spielern einfach nur sagen muss, du müsstest einen halben Kilometer mehr laufen. Und da machen die das auch. So würde ich mir das wünschen in allen Lebenslagen, wenn man irgendwie mit Kindern oder Schutzbefohlenen zu tun hat, wenn ich das meinen Kindern beim Aufräumen vorhin hätte sagen können, wäre ich ein bisschen entspannter hier zu dieser Aufnahme gekommen. Aber woher ist denn dann oder wie ist denn dann zu erklären, dass diese Spiele immer noch so wild sind? Liegt das jetzt im Zorniger Ball oder woher kommt das?
Ich glaube, wenn sie das selbst wüssten bei der Spielform, dann würden sie es ändern. Also weil die sind sehr genervt, wenn ich da immer danach frag, warum da keine Konstanz ist. Weil auch im vergangenen Jahr hat Alexander Zorniger vor knapp einem Jahr übernommen. Also Ende Oktober 2022, letzten Wochen Podcast, Werbung an der Stelle mit ihm aufgenommen, über sein einjähriges hinführt. Und damals hat er schon so nach 2, 3 Monaten gesagt, jetzt müssten wir Konstanzen in unsere Leistungen bringen, war immer die Aussage. Und immer so, wenn es möglich war, mal vom 11. auf den 8. Platz zu springen, da haben sie gefühlt immer verloren. Und das war in der Song lange auch wieder so. Immer wenn sie die Möglichkeit hatten, wieder nach oben zu kommen, dann hat es wieder nicht geklappt. Und auch das ist wieder so was, diese Konstanz, die bereitet, glaube ich, Alexander Zornäger schon ein großes Kopf zerbrechen. Weil es ist nicht erklärbar. An manchen Spieltagen sind sie extrem gut. Jetzt auch das Aussatzspiel in Kaiserslautern. Nachdem man ja da spielt, ein klarer Aufstiegsfavorit. Und dann hat man 4 Tage vorher das Pokalspiel in Homburg gesehen. Es lieb einfach gar nichts. Es war einfach schlecht. Max, für dich 35 Flanken aus dem Halbfeld.
Völlig verdient ausgeschieden. Ich hab nichts gesehen.
Ja, fand ich auch. Vor allem 35 Flanken auf Brusthöhe vom Verteidiger ist immer besonders wichtig auf den 1. Pfosten. Also ist es dann schön, wenn man da drüber schreiben muss und da auch Bewertungen zu treffen muss. Macht sehr viel Spaß. Da ist natürlich auch das passiert, was du vorhin angesprochen hast, für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die es nicht wissen. Ich hab einen Kommentar geschrieben nach dem Pokal aus, dass sich alle in Fürth hinterfragen müssen und hab da ein paar Fragen aufgeworfen, die ich drängend fand. Alexander Zornik hat all diese Fragen auf einem Zettel dabei gehabt bei einer PK und hat in seinem Eingangsstatement 8,5 Minuten über diese Fragen geredet. Ich fand es eine große Wertschätzung für meine Arbeit. Aber es war schon etwas skurril, muss man so sagen. Hab ich deine Frage jetzt beantwortet? Ich glaube nicht.
Na ja, doch. Du hast im Grunde gesagt, dass es die Fürther selber nicht wissen, warum da eine Konstanz ist und dass man sich erklären kann. Gleichzeitig haben wir abgehandelt, warum Alexander Zorninger diesen langen Monolog gehalten hat, bei dem er sicherlich einen niedrigen Blutdruck hatte, so wie ich ihn einschätze.
Ich fand, er hatte einen sehr niedrigen Blutdruck. Ein bisschen kurios war es schon.
Ich muss sagen, ich gucke mir nicht unbedingt die Fürth-Pressekonferenzen an, aber es war ja plötzlich überall auf Social Media. Auch auf den Sportschau-Kanälen. Wir haben es überall gemacht. Weil es so kurios war und man so dachte, okay, was ist denn los in Fürth plötzlich? Guckt man jetzt nicht jedes Wochenende unbedingt vielleicht hin, aber da war es schon...
Man sieht es an den YouTube-Abrufzahlen der PK. Die ist selten so hoch wie bei dieser jetzt. Aber es ist ja schön, wenn Fürth auch ein bisschen bekannt wird.
Klaus Augenthaler, damals die Frage stelle ich, die Antworten gebe ich auch. Und eine Minute 48 später war die Pressekonferenz vorbei. Und hier war es quasi so wie eins Trappattoni mit dem Zettel. Aber Trappattoni hat weniger Fragen beantwortet, muss man ehrlicherweise sagen als Alexander Zorniger.
Das hat mich ein bisschen an der Rezeption dieser PK schon gestört. Du hörst das immer überall von Augenthaler, wie du jetzt auch sagst, Max, die Rede war, weil es war ja nicht so, dass er sich selbst Fragen gestellt hat. Er hat ja die Fragen aus einem Kommentar vorgelesen. Das fand ich war schon mal eine andere Sache.
Die kam ja von dir.
Aber es stand überall Augenthaler. Wenn ich auf mein Konto schaue, dann schauen wir mal.
Die sollen endlich mal hier sich für Podcasts öffnen. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber wo steht denn deine Meinung nach Fürth aktuell? Also wenn es so ein bisschen schwierig einzuschätzen ist, dann ist es ja auch schwer zu sagen, wo die Reise hingeht. Aber Fürth versucht ja, eine Entwicklung durchzumachen. Und gleichzeitig begegnet man immer mal wieder der Vergangenheit. Wenn ich eben sehe, dass ein Christiansen nach Hannover wechselt. Wenn ich sehe, dass man gegen Hannover 1 zu 3 verliert. Mit Stefan Leitl, der dann eben wieder zurückkehrt. Das heißt, da bietet sich ja immer wieder dieser Vergleich an zur Aufstiegssaison und wo man da jetzt im Vergleich sich hin entwickelt hat.
Ja, es ist extrem schwierig. Ich muss natürlich auch sagen, dass Fürth an den meisten Spieltagen die jüngste Startelf der Liga hat. Ich glaube, letztens war eine Statistik, dass der HSV noch sehr jung ist. Der Klub ist mittlerweile auch sehr jung. Da kommt man vielleicht noch drauf auf diese vielen Eigengewächse aus dem NLZ beim Klub. Die Hertha ist noch relativ jung mit vielen Spielern oder vom Berliner Weg, wie ich gelernt habe. Auch schön, der XY-Weg. In Fürth gibt es auch immer den Viertelweg. Es gibt den Berliner Weg, es gibt überall den XY-Weg. Und der ist immer so ganz besonders. Das hat man auch mit Tim schon mal von Mille Antoni an dieser Stelle.
Manchmal ist es eine Sackgasse, manchmal ist es ein Bänderhammer. Und manchmal tatsächlich eine Serpentinenstraße, die nach oben führt.
Ich finde es positiv, wenn ich sage, auch es ist eine Serpentinenstraße, die ganz langsam nach oben führt. Man kann natürlich schon sagen, man kam jetzt auch gar nicht auf die Neuzugänge, die im Sommer kamen, aber sehr viele junge Spieler geholt. Zum Beispiel Robert Wagner vom SC Freiburg, der in der 3. Liga einer der besten Spieler war, der mittlerweile auch Stammspieler ist, spielt die ganze Zeit auf der 6., wo er eigentlich 8. ist. Die sind einfach 20 Jahre alt. Da ist es vielleicht sogar normal, dass es Leistungsschwankungen gibt. Ich hatte auch Zornigge immer auf dieses 0-5 angesprochen in Berlin. Das war schon eine harte Abreibung, aber gefühlt waren auch die Expected Goals und die Torchancen relativ gleich. Aber man hat hinten alles kassiert und vorne keine Tore gemacht. Und er sagte ihm war es sogar lieber, dass man vielleicht mal 0-5 verliert, dass die jungen Spieler auch mal merken, was passiert, wenn man nur 80 statt 100% gibt. Und dass das vielleicht zu einem Lernprozess dazu gehört. Man muss ja auch sagen, seitdem ist es nicht mehr so. In der letzten Saison hat Zorniger immer von einem gewissen Abfalllevel gesprochen. Klingt immer ein bisschen blöd, wenn man bei Menschen vom Abfalllevel spricht. Aber er meint natürlich, dass er levelt, dass es nach unten abfällt. Und er findet, dass es nicht mehr so stark ist. Und es ist auch nicht mehr so, dass es so krasse Aussetzer-Spiele gibt in der vergangenen Saison. Dass man jetzt nur eins der letzten sieben verloren hat, ist schon mal gut. Weil in der Saison zu Hause weiterhin fast alles gewonnen. Also vier von sechs gewonnen. Letztes Jahr, glaube ich, von der Zorniger sieben von zehn gewonnen. Also die Heimstärke ist schon mal da. Also was führt halt immer so in den Weg, steht in dieser Auswärtsschwäche. Und ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt, was auf dieses 0-2, also 2-0 in Kaislautern jetzt folgt. Ob man das auch mal auswärts hinkriegt, kontinuierlich gut zu spielen. Weil, dass diese Mannschaft das drin hat, sehr gute Spiele abzuliefern, hat sehr oft nachgewiesen. Nur, das was halt alle immer rätst, ist, dass diese Inkonstanz, die für mich nur durchs Alter erklärbar ist. Und natürlich die vielen Wechseln, die man dann doch hatte vor der Saison.
Und wie ist es zu erklären, dass die Transferstrategie, zumindest nach außen hin, sich verändert hat? Wenn ich mir anschaue, also zur Saison 22, 23, da hatte man mit Levelling und Gangkamp noch zwei Abgänge, für die man ganz gut Geld bekommen hat. Deswegen konnte man auch rund 2,5 Millionen Euro investieren in Spiele. Dieses Jahr komplett anders, also zu dieser Saison hin, meine ich natürlich. 700.000 hat man so grob eingenommen für Spieler, 300.000 investiert und viele Leihspieler. Also gerade Robert Wagner, den du ja gerade angesprochen hast, auch Lämpere vom 1. FC Köln, Ulrik vom 1. FC Köln, das werden auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer vielleicht mitbekommen haben. Gibt es da eine Veränderung in der Transferstrategie oder ist das jetzt einfach Zufall?
Ich habe damit rasch, wie das Husi mit dem Sportgeschäftsführer sehr lange darüber geredet, im Sommer im Trainingslager, und er findet, dass das so eine Gesamtentwicklung im Profifußball vielleicht sogar ist, dass viele junge Spieler, die früher mal zu einem Verein, wie der Spielverein, gewechselt wären, mittlerweile lieber bei ihren Stammvereinen bleiben, weil es diesen Verein nicht wehtut, solchen Spielern mal einen Profivertrag zu geben und sie einfach dann dreimal auszuleihen. Er sagt, es ist fast unmöglich, Spieler dieser Güteklasse, das sind ja alles auch U21-Nationalspieler. Also Urbeck, Lämperey und Wagner sind ja mittlerweile sogar Stammspieler. Also Urbeck hat statt Noah Atubolo, der ja auch in aller Munde ist, der SC Freiburg Stammtorwart ist, als er mal krank war, statt ihm in der U21 gespielt. Also es ist eigentlich so die Nummer 2 der U21. Robert Wagner hat immer gespielt, Lämperey spielt meist im Sturm dort. Und er sagt, solche Spieler hätte man halt vor ein paar Jahren womöglich sogar noch kaufen können. Und mittlerweile ist es offenbar illusorisch, also auch die Gehälter, die diese Vereine verdienen, diese Spieler verdienen, bei diesen großen Vereinen, sagt er, sie kann so einen kleiner Verein wie Fürth nicht zahlen. Und deswegen muss er mehr Leichspieler holen. Ich meine, wenn man den Vergleich zieht, andere Vereine schaffen das schon auch. Also Holstein Kiel hat auch viele neue, junge Spieler auch geholt. Die haben, glaube ich, nur Tom Roth ausgeliehen, bild ich mir ein. Also nur einen Leichspieler. Und vielleicht muss man im Scouting kreativer sein, aber da möchte ich jetzt nicht da auch nochmal in die Tiefe gehen. Aber eigentlich möchte man das nicht ändern. Man ist weiterhin auf diese Transferlöse angewiesen. Was sich in Fürth schon auch ein bisschen verändert hat, ist, dass man sehr viele junge Spieler allgemein holt, weil es ja diese DFL-Nachwuchs-Säule gibt, für die es ja, glaub, mittlerweile sind es 4% der Medienerlöse seit der vergangenen Saison. Früher waren es mal 3% der Medienerlöse. Da war Fürth im letzten Jahr Spitze. Und das wollen sie natürlich wieder sein, weil sie dann nochmal 2,5 oder 3 Millionen extra bekommen. Und das ist ja schon der Verkauf von ein oder zwei Spielern. Deswegen müssen auch, was ich, also es bestätigt natürlich niemand, aber angeblich müssen pro Spiel 4 oder müssen 4 U23-Spieler Stammspieler entführt sein, was man so hört.
Okay. Und geht das dann auch konform mit dem, was Alexander Zorninger mit dem Verein erreichen will? Weil, also man kann sowieso ganz schwer nur mit einem Aufstieg jetzt kalkulieren. Wir alle wissen, wie eng die 2. Liga ist. Und auf die wirtschaftlichen Rahmenfaktoren hast du ja gerade auch schon indirekt hingewiesen. Da ist jetzt natürlich auch Fürth jetzt nicht bei den obersten Teams mit dabei, auch wenn man natürlich ein etablierter Zweitligist ist. Ich habe Alexander Zorninger aber an seinen bisherigen Stationen immer als sehr ehrgeizig wahrgenommen. Er hätte dann jetzt unterstellt, dass es da dann schon Richtung Aufstieg zumindest gehen sollte mit seinem Team. Fehlinterpretiere ich da?
Überhaupt nicht. Er ist immer noch selbstbewusst, wie bei seinem Amtsantritt. Letztens hatte ich ihn darauf angesprochen, weil er im vergangenen Jahr immer meinte, er sei besser im Fürth etwas spielen als im Gegenetwas spielen. Das ist eine Zorninger Formulierung, die mir im Kopf geblieben ist, als es immer so gegen den Abstieg ging. Und dann habe ich darauf angesprochen, wofür er denn in der Saison spielen wollte. Und dann hat er gesagt, sein Ziel ist immer noch, mit Fürth um Titel zu spielen. Blöderweise war das vier Tage vor der Aufnahme, die Aufnahme war vier Tage vor dem Pokal aus in Hamburg. Das heißt, der eine Titel, der möglich ist, der, wenn man auch auf die Zusammensetzung des Achtelfinales blickt, auch vielleicht sogar leichter möglich gewesen wäre, als in früheren Jahren, der ist schon mal weg. Das heißt, ein anderer Titel kann dann nur sein, eine Meisterschaft oder ein Aufstieg mit Fürth. Das würde in Fürth niemand so sagen. Ich finde es sehr erfrischend, weil in Fürth macht man sich schon gerne, oftmals auch kleiner. Man sagt aber, er ist der kleine Verein. Das kriegen alle mit, die auf diesen Verein achten. Deswegen ist auch die mediale Aufmerksamkeit nicht allzu groß. Aber ich würde es erfrischend, dass da jemand ist, der sagt, ich möchte mit Fürth auch Titel gewinnen. Und ich nehme ihm das auch ab. Ich glaube, das ist für ihn schon auch, das ist meine reine Interpretation. Auch schwierig ist es anzuerkennen, dass er bei einem Verein ist, wo es vielleicht schwieriger zu erreichen ist, als bei Brøndby-Koppenhagen, wo er dann mal dänischer Pokalsieger wurde, oder in Zypern, wo er zyperotischer Meister wurde, mit Fürth aufzusteigen. Das haben auch schon andere Trainer geschafft. Aber es wäre trotzdem auch in dieser Saison wieder eine Überraschung. Und ich will es auch mal nicht zu weit gehen, zu sagen, dass die Spiele eine aufsteigende Saison.
Da möchte er sich nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen, was ich ihm gerade geöffnet habe. Aber dann sag mir doch nochmal zum Abschluss, weil du hast jetzt schon ein paar Spielernamen genannt, aber es scheint mir so zu sein, dass da noch mehr rumlaufen bei der Spielvereinigung, auf die man ein Auge haben sollte. Wer sind so die Spieler, wo du sagst, die könnten auch in Zukunft eine Rolle spielen, weil wenn wir hier schon so ein junges Team haben, dann müssen da ja auch einige Spieler der Zukunft dabei sein.
Also ich finde, die besten Spieler, der beste Spieler des ganzen Kalenderjahres in Fürth, das sind ja schon dann über 11 Monate, das ist auf jeden Fall Truling Green. Das ist wirklich krass zu sehen. Der war ja in Stuttgart, also bei den Bayern in Stuttgart, beim HSV, dann ist er ja, glaube ich, 2017 nach Fürth gekommen. Also er ist schon relativ lange auch hier und er hat immer wieder so gute Phasen, so 10 Spiele, denen er überragend war und dann ist er wieder ein paar Spiele abgetaucht und er spielt einfach dieses ganze Jahr mit Ausnahme von vielleicht zwei Spielen, extrem konstanter, glaube ich, drei Tore und sechs Vorlagen. Jetzt erwischt du mich, Kaltmax. Aber er ist auf jeden Fall der Top-Scorer der Spielvereinigung momentan. Extrem gut, er spielt dort diese 8, das ist im 3-4-1-2, diese alleinige 8. Position, wo er eigentlich, also er spielt vor Robert Wagner, aber er muss auch mal sich tiefer fallen lassen, muss aber auch in den 10er-Raum vorstoßen. Wenn man Herr Gotthard, der ja so großer Freigeist ist, irgendwie sich nach außen fallen lässt. Also das ist einfach eine extrem anschlussvolle Position, weil also das gesamte Zentrum eigentlich von Strafe, also ich will jetzt nicht Box-zu-Box-Spieler sagen, weil das ist er nicht, aber er muss schon das gesamte Zentrum so beackern und das macht er einfach extrem, extrem gut. Geht da krass voran. Ich hab eine Szene vor Augen. Jetzt am kommenden Wochenende in Kaiserslautern wurde Walid Mamdi, ein sehr junger Spieler, eingewechselt und der hat dann am eigenen Strafe um den Ball verloren und dann hat Green über den halben Platz gesprintet und hat ihn zurechtgewiesen. Also das zeigt auch diese gewachsene Rolle von Julian Green in Fürth und der ist mittlerweile auch Ersatzkapitän. Das war er jahrelang nicht. Er ist jetzt auch Ersatzkapitän. Also wenn der Goethe, auch so eine Geschichte, der öfter ausgewechselt wird mittlerweile, auch frühzeitig mal, so nach 70 Minuten, dann ist er einfach immer Julian Green der Kapitän. Das hat man Fürth auch lange nicht gedacht, weil er so ein bisschen als zurück vielleicht galt. Das ist er jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht. Brandy Mayer-Goethe muss man auch immer sagen. Also in Kaislautern fand ich ihn auch extrem gut bei dem Spiel. Hat aber auch schon zwei Elfmeter verschossen in der Saison. Brandy Mayer-Goethe weiß ja aber keine Elfmeter mehr schießen darf in Fürth. Wurde eben von Zornig er verboten. Julian Green ist jetzt der Elfmeterschütze. Aber trotzdem bislang wieder der Top-Torschütze des Spiels, vor allem mit vier Toren. Ja, und dann müssen wir noch über Luca Etta sprechen. Auch so ein Spieler, der in der Bundesliga in Fürth ja schon da war, der jetzt aber auch in so eine größere Rolle gewachsen ist, der früher ja Linksverteidiger war, kam ja vom SC Freiburg damals nach Fürth. Als Linksverteidiger, glaube sogar die Fritz-Walter-Medaille hatte er damals gehabt. Und spielt jetzt diesen linken Innenverteidiger in der Dreierkette. Macht das extrem gut, extrem routiniert im Spielaufbau, sehr gut. Erschauendlich abgeklärt. Und Zornig hat jetzt auch nach dem Pokalspiel in Homburg gesagt, dass dieses Spiel aber eines gezeigt hat, dass Luca Etta nicht zu ersetzen sei in der Mannschaft. Bitte reikennen, dass er erst gerade verletzt oder angeschlagen. Das heißt, er muss mal ihn ersetzen, bald. Und dann würde ich als 4. Spieler noch Maximilian Dietz nennen, den ich vorhin schon mal kurz gedroppt habe. Der kam vom SC Freiburg aus der 2. Mannschaft, war auch Nachwuchsspieler des SC Freiburg. Wird sich jetzt Nick Steiger, zum Beispiel wieder Freund, der schon mal eine Mannschaft aufgestellt hat, aus Jugendspielern des SC Freiburg. Und er ist auch einer davon, aber gar keiner dieser großen Namen. Er hat halt in der Freiburger U19 gespielt. Aber ich glaube, nur ein Spiel beim SC Freiburg 2 in der 3. Liga und kam dann zur Spielvereinigung zur 2. Mannschaft, als explizit U23-Spieler, und wurde da relativ schnell Kapitän im vergangenen Jahr. Ich habe da damals das, habe ich noch vor Augen, für alle die es nicht kennen, die D. Filzing. Ein Spitzenmannschaft aus der Regionalliga Bayern. Ich glaube, momentan 2. Platz sogar in der Regionalliga Bayern. Aber halt aus der Oberpfalz, also Max wird es kennen, alle anderen Hörerinnen und Hörer wahrscheinlich eher weniger, wenn sie nicht aus Bayern stammen. Aber schon das Klischee Dorfverein eher. Die haben dagegen so einen Verein verloren. Da spricht er vor so kratzigen Lautsprechern auf so einem Sportplatz mit mir. Ein Jahr später ist er Stammspieler bei der Spielfahne in der 2. Liga, macht 10 von 12 Startelfeinsätzen. Macht das extrem routiniert, hat schon auch Tiefen gehabt. Ist ja auch klar beim Spieler, er ist 21. Dass er mal Fehler macht bei der Härte, wurde er nach 35 Minuten ausgewechselt, weil er so viele Fehler und Probleme hatte. Aber insgesamt extrem routiniert, ballsicher. In Fürth wird er schon von manchmal als der zukünftige Kapitän gesehen. Schauen wir mal, in ein, zwei Jahren vielleicht mal drüber sprechen, wenn er dann noch da ist. Wenn er die Entwicklung so weiterhält, ist er wahrscheinlich auch einfach nicht mehr da. Das kann auch sein. Ja, ich würde mal sagen, lohnt sich es zu achten.
Eben, jetzt einfach Fortuna wegputzen und dann aufsteigen und dann sehen wir alle Maximilian Dietz. Dann kann man ihn vielleicht halten. Jetzt auf einmal ist er sich wieder unsicher, der Michael, während er es doch vorhin selber so prognostiziert hat. Aber das ist einfach das gebrannte Kind, das scheut das Feuer, das haben alle Förderinnen und Förder schon mal erlebt und von Fürth zu Nürnberg ist der Weg sowieso nicht weit. Aber auch in dieser Hinsicht ist er es nicht. Denn auch die Klubbererinnen und Klubberer sind gebrannte Kinder. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann es war, aber ich hatte wieder irgendeine Lesung und dann bin ich mit den Klubberern gemeinsam aus meiner unterfränkischen Heimat über Nürnberg dann nach München gefahren und habe die in Nürnberg dann alle aussteigen lassen. Und da habe ich Lisa wieder das ganze Portfolio der Emotionen erlebt, was aber auch einfach immer bei Klubberern da ist. Ich komme ja aus der Gegend, deswegen weiß ich das. Es war eben von absolutem Optimismus. Wir sind ein sicherer Aufsteiger bis hin zu der Trainer muss weg, alles ist schlecht, keiner von denen kann irgendwie kicken. Wie ist es denn nun wirklich?
Ja, wenn es die eine wahre Antwort gäbe, Max, wenn es die gäbe, dann hätten wir ein paar Themen weniger wahrscheinlich. Aber ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das, was ja die Fans, auch den Verein und das ganze Umfeld so ein bisschen beschreibt und was es gar nicht so einfach macht, wenn man dann in diesem Verein steckt oder wenn man dann die Erwartungen irgendwie managen muss. Also mein Gefühl ist, Aufsteiger sind wir diese Saison nicht mit dem ersten FC Nürnberg. Nee, das würde ich jetzt noch nicht callen. Es ist sehr eng, ja. Ich habe mir auch Statistik hier mäßig aufgeschrieben, der beste Tabellenelfte der Zweitliga-Geschichte zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Das klingt doch eigentlich auch ganz schlecht.
Steht das schon auf dem Briefkopf?
Bei mir jetzt noch nicht. Aber könnte man sich zumindest mal in die Instagram-Bio reinschreiben, wenn man nach einem kleinen Zwischenerfolg sucht. Dass es da wahnsinnig eng ist, das gefühlt im Moment in der 2. Liga jeder gegen jeden gewinnen kann, aber auch verlieren kann. Ich glaube, da müssen wir gar nicht groß drüber sprechen. Und so war es ja beim Club diese Saison auch ein bisschen bislang. Es ist so ein kleines Auf und Ab. Ein paar Sachen, die Michi gerade aus der Fürther-Bubble erzählt hat, kommen mir da als Club-Fan auch tatsächlich sehr bekannt vor. Da hast du gute Spiele, dann kriegst du mal wieder eine Klatsche, wie 5-1 auf St. Pauli, wo du dich auffragst, es läuft doch eigentlich gerade alles ganz okay. Und man ist so vorsichtig optimistisch. Und dann kommt so ein Spiel da rein, dass es vielleicht auch einfach mal braucht, ja. Aber ich würde sagen, wie immer, ist die Wahrheit irgendwo in der Mitte, Max. Wir werden, glaube ich, als Club-Fans dieses Jahr nicht unbedingt um den Aufstieg mitspielen. Ich habe aber auch Hoffnung, wie die Saison bislang gelaufen ist, dass wir den Klassenerhalt vor dem letzten Spieltag im Sack haben. Wenn man an die letzte Saison denkt, es war doch noch knapp. Ich glaube, das hat der eine oder andere auch schon wieder vergessen, weil der Hype sich jetzt so ein bisschen aufgebaut hat die letzten Wochen. Aber wenn man guckt, wo der Verein herkommt, was vor einem halben, dreiviertel Jahr los war, dann bin ich gerade relativ entspannt, dass man das Gefühl hat, da entsteht was. Da sind viele Leute an den richtigen Positionen und es wird vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen ruhiger. Und man sollte auch nicht zu schnell zu viele Träume haben. Aber da mache ich mir eigentlich im Verein und in der Mannschaft auch gar keine Probleme, ehrlicherweise. Ich glaube, die sind da schon sehr sortiert. Gerade auch mit Christian Vient als Trainer.
Genau, über den hätte ich jetzt nämlich ganz gerne mal gesprochen. Weil ich habe nämlich auch noch den Club in der letzten Saison. Also das war knapp. Und letztlich waren einfach ein paar andere Teams noch schlechter als der Club. Ich glaube, so fand ich, dass das Saison-Final ist. Tut mir leid, das so offen zu sagen.
Nee, das ist schon ehrlich ein Stück weit.
Und jetzt ist man ja eigentlich mit Ausnahme des Saisonstarts. 0-2 in Rostock, dann 2-2 gegen Hannover. Da hiel man so ein bisschen unten drin. Aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich relativ solide. Es gab dann noch drei Niederlagen gegen Lautern, gegen St. Pauli, beides auswärts. Und jetzt zu Hause gegen Schalke. Und gegen Schalke verliebt man ja immer zu Hause. Das funktioniert ja irgendwie.
Irgendwie auch so ein Gesetz. Das ist auch ein bisschen komisch langsam.
Ja, alle abgelenkt vor der Correo wahrscheinlich. Anders kann es ja eigentlich kaum sein. Aber ansonsten ist das ja eben relativ stabil. Und vor allem mit relativ vielen Siegen. Das ist ja auch was, was dem Club oft gefehlt hat. Der Club hat sehr oft Unentschieden gespielt. Zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung, wo andere Teams einfach irgendwie noch einen Sieg rausdrücken. Wie viel hat das denn jetzt mit dem neuen Trainer, mit Christian Fjeld zu tun?
Ich glaube, das ist schon ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Baustein. Also wenn man sich die Gesamtkonstellation anguckt, dann ist mit Christian Fjeld da jetzt, glaube ich, jemand installiert, der nicht komplett fremd ist, der ja den Verein schon ein paar Jahre kennt, der das Umfeld kennt, der auch, glaube ich, ganz gut damit umzugehen weiß, welche Stimmungen da von außen dann auch mal ran getragen werden, dass es vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen schneller unruhig wird. Ein großer Vorteil natürlich, dass er die zweite Mannschaft trainiert hat, dass er auch die jüngeren Spieler, die ja jetzt wirklich immer, immer wichtiger werden, auch in der ersten Mannschaft, dass er viele von denen kennt, dass er, glaube ich, einen richtig, richtig guten Umgang mit denen hat und dass da gerade eine Mannschaft, so wirkt das auf mich, wirklich so zusammenfindet. Also auf dem Platz, finde ich, kann man das ganz gut sehen. Du hast gesagt, viele Siege, ja, und was mich ja vor allem freut, viele Siege, nachdem man in Rückstand war. Also ich habe die Statistik jetzt nicht parat. Ich bin nicht so der Statistiker wie Michi, der hier so ein richtiges Portfolio schon mitgebracht hat. Aber es ist nicht nur gefühlte Wahrheit, sondern man kann es sehr gut sich auch nachgucken. Das war vor zwei, drei Jahren nämlich noch ganz, ganz anders. Wenn du da als Clubfanspiel gesehen hast und wusstest, du liegst 1-0 hinten, dann hast du dich gefreut, wenn vielleicht noch ein Punkt rausgesprungen ist. Aber dass wirklich das Spiel gedreht wird, das gab es halt doch eher selten. Und ich finde, das ist etwas, was man in der Saison sehr, sehr merkt, auch wenn erste Halbzeit im ein oder anderen Spiel hergeschenkt wird. Wenn du denkst, oh Gott, da läuft heute nichts, dann kommt die Mannschaft oft sehr verändert aus der Kabine, wo ich mir immer wünschen würde, ich könnte mal hören, was Christian Fjell da loslässt oder wie die Ansprache. Da ist es ja ein sehr leidenschaftlicher Typ. Das kriegt man ja auch in den Interviews ganz gut mit, dass ich mir immer so denke, Mensch, da würde ich gerne mal so ein bisschen Mäuschen spielen, weil man da schon oft merkt, okay, da kommt eine ganz andere Truppe dann plötzlich raus und tritt da ganz anders auf und glaubt auch einfach dran. Also ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl, man hatte gerade am Ende der letzten Saison ja gefühlt schon irgendwie Angst, dann was falsch zu machen an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Es wollte der eine oder andere gefühlt den Ball gar nicht haben. Es ist nach vorne nicht viel passiert. Und es gab dieses Abstiegsszenario, Relegations-Szenario, das von Woche zu Woche größer wurde und das wie so eine Wolke irgendwie über einem schwebte und verständlicherweise dann natürlich das auch ein bisschen komplizierter gemacht hat im Kopf an der einen oder anderen Stelle, würde ich behaupten. Und das sehe ich jetzt halt komplett verändert, dass da eine junge Truppe ist mit so Spielern wie Gian Uso und mit einem Nene Braun. Die sind super jung, die sind irgendwie auch nicht vorbelastet, die sind sehr positiv optimistisch, die haben einfach Spaß an dem, was sie tun, was finde ich schon ein ganz, ganz guter Ansatz ist. Aber auch die Truppe an sich wirkt mir sehr, sehr stimmig, was man auf dem Platz sieht, aber auch was man hört, wie untereinander, übereinander gesprochen wird. Dass es eine relativ große Gruppe gibt, die auch viel privat macht. Man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, das stimmt da einfach an sehr vielen Stellen gerade. Und das macht mir eigentlich Mut, dass da gerade was entsteht. Deswegen aufstehe ich jetzt dieses Jahr, diese Saison, glaube ich, auch noch zu früh finden. Das wäre dann wahrscheinlich einfach der Schritt zu schnell. Aber wenn die Mannschaft, so wie sie im Moment ist, zusammenbleibt und man jetzt nicht nächstes Jahr im Sommer einen Gian Uson oder einen Nene Braun, man hört ja immer Bundesligisten haben Interesse, Eintracht Frankfurt klopft an, Ausland und so. Wenn man die vielleicht noch das ein oder andere Jahr hält, dann wäre ich fürs nächste Jahr schon deutlich optimistischer, was Punktenlosen anginge.
Also es gibt nur ein Team, das mehr Punkte nach Rückstand geholt hat als der Club und das ist vollstreng hier.
Hast du das jetzt nachgeguckt oder weißt du es auswendig?
Nein, natürlich wird es nachgeguckt.
Ja, also zwei schon geschockt gemacht.
Ich bitte dich, ich schaffe nicht, irgendwelche Choreos mitzubekommen und was vom Spieltag zu sehen, aber das habe ich natürlich.
Also es gibt ja so Leute, die können ja wirklich jede Statistik dir runterbeeten. Ich muss auch alles nachgucken, sage ich euch. Aber gut, guck mal, das war nicht nur eine gefühlte Wahrheit.
Genau, also neun Rückstände, neun Punkte daraus geholt. Heustern Kiel, achtmal zurückgelegen, zehn Punkte daraus geholt. Tatsächlich gibt es nur ein Team hier in der Runde, das nach Rückstand bisher noch gar nicht gewonnen hat. Achtmal lag man schon zurück. Jörn weiß schon, ja, der KSC ist gemeint, aber das... Wenn man KSC-Spiele so ein bisschen mitverfolgt hat, dann kommt das jetzt nicht so überraschend. Jetzt hast du sehr begeistert erzählt von Christian Fiel. Bei Christian Fiel ärgere ich mich immer noch. Ich hatte in der kurzen Phase zwischen Dresden und Nürnberg, da hätte ich ihn für ein Tribüngespräch haben können und ich hab's terminlich nicht hinbekommen. Ich Vollidiot. Und jetzt kriege ich natürlich kein offenes Wort mehr von ihm, weil jetzt riskiert er damit den Ausstieg beim Klub. Deswegen muss ich warten, bis er wieder in-between Jobs ist. Das ist immer der beste Moment für ehrliche Gespräche.
Was hat denn Robert Klaus gerade? Mit dem würde ich auch gerne noch mal.
Ja, Robert Klaus würde ja allein von der Terminologie sehr gut in den Rasenpunkt passen. Das muss man ja ehrlicherweise so sagen.
Das stimmt eigentlich. Den vermisse ich so ein bisschen auf der Bildfläche, weil den habe ich jetzt gerade verkraftet, dass er nicht mehr beim Klub als Trainer ist. Und das ist jetzt okay. Aber das wäre doch mal jemand. Da würde ich einfach mal den Input geben. Dann nimm doch den anderen ehemaligen Klub-Trainer.
Also, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, habe ich ihn neulich im Kicker-Meets-the-Sauen-Podcast gesehen. Also, ich habe es nicht gehört, aber deswegen... Ja, doch, das müsste jetzt gerade erst gewesen sein. Folge Nummer 187. Aber lasst uns nicht über irgendwelche nicht-verrealisierten Rasenfunk-Sendungen sprechen. Du bist jetzt sehr, ja nicht euphorisch, aber sehr positiv gewesen über alles, was du über den Klub erzählt hast. Ist es denn auch übereinstimmend mit der Spielweise des Klubs? Hat sich da denn was verändert?
Ich finde, sie spielen endlich wieder Fußball. Also das ist das, was es für mich zusammenbringt. Also wenn ihr uns jetzt nur hört und nicht seht, es wurde gerade schon herzlich gelacht. Aber wenn man sich zurückerinnert, welcher Antifußball unter einem Trainer Weinziel noch vor einem guten Jahr stattgefunden hat, das hat für mich nicht so wirklich viel Spaß gemacht. Klar, die Konstellation war eine andere, aber ich finde, jetzt kannst du schon als Fan auch wieder gerne die Spiele gucken. Also du siehst, da ist eine Spielidee da. Die Mannschaft will kicken, die wollen Tore machen. Die haben natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen das Problem, es gibt nicht den klassischen Mittelstürmer. Also wenn wir überlegen, auch da guckst du bestimmt jetzt sofort nach, Max, was für eine Statistik dazu passt, wie viele Torchancen es gäbe, die aber nicht ansatzweise irgendwie genutzt wurden. Also auch gerade jetzt letztes Spiel im Pokal gegen Rostock, ich weiß gar nicht, 13, 14 Ecken, und nix ist bei rumgekommen, da stand keiner halbwegs richtig. Ja, da ist noch Nachholbedarf, auch was die Verwertung von richtig, richtig, richtig guten Chancen angeht, auch gerade von den Neuzugängen, Okunoki, einer der beiden Japaner, da denke ich mir, man wünscht so ein Quäntchen-Mehrzug noch, oder auch Benny Golla, der sich richtig gemacht hat, aber da wird schon noch relativ viel liegen gelassen gerade. Aber selbst das ist irgendwie aus Fansicht gesprochen, für mich gerade gar nicht so schlimm, weil ich das Gefühl habe, da wächst was zusammen und die kicken wirklich endlich wieder. Vor allem das kennt man doch, oder? Und das ist doch schön, da bin ich jetzt mal dabei. Das ist nicht mehr so ein Anti-Fußball. Und wenn du dann verlierst, oder wenn es dann auch mal blöd läuft, klar, die Niederlage, das 2-1 gegen Schalke, das war halt absolut unnötig. Also ein Punkt wäre mindestens verdient gewesen, wenn man sich das Spiel angeguckt hat. Aber selbst da war ich dann, also ja, ich war auch ein bisschen traurig, weil rechnerisch hätten wir auch Dritter werden können, so ungefähr, oder zumindest Fürther, das ist ja alles sehr eng.
Rechnerisch kann gerade fast jeder Dritter werden.
Also wir hätten sehr, sehr weit mit dem FCN nach oben springen können. Da hab ich dann als Fan auch kurz gedacht, ach, das wäre schon schön, so ein guter, einstelliger Tabellenplatz. Dann dachte ich aber, ach na ja, vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht, dann kommt jetzt keiner zu schnell ins Träumen. Und es war trotzdem kein schlechtes Spiel. Also ich hab trotzdem das Gefühl gehabt, okay, das war jetzt ein gutes Spiel, das verlierst du dann halt auch mal. Ja, okay, aber du gehst nicht negativ nach Hause, weil es trotzdem Bock gemacht hat. Und weil du siehst, da sind gerade Jungs, die haben Bock, die können was. Und wir haben über das Alter und über junge Spieler ja schon so ein bisschen gesprochen und haben das ein bisschen angeritzen. Und das ist ja gerade das, was mir im Moment auch wirklich Spaß macht beim Club. Also dass wirklich viele Junge jetzt nachkommen, dass die ihre Chancen bekommen. Über Giannuso und Nene Brown haben wir schon gesprochen. Das sind ja im Endeffekt schon Stammspieler mehr oder weniger, wenn die fit sind. Und die haben sich da richtig etabliert. Aber auch was dahinter herkommt, ob das ein Ali Luhn ist, der ja auch schon Spiele gemacht hat, ob wir einen U17-Europameister haben beim Club mit Finn Yelch, der jetzt auch einen Profi-Protrag bekommen hat. Also da sind noch ein paar hinten dran. Und das ist schon das, wo ich sage, so musst du es machen. Auch die Spieler, die jetzt schon das eine oder andere Jahr beim Club sind, Duman, Kastrop, die sind auch alle super jung. Und das ist so ein bisschen das, wo ich sage, okay, wenn du die Beile zusammenhältst, noch ein Jahr, noch zwei, natürlich wirst du einen Gian Uso. Und wenn er sich weiter so entwickelt, jetzt schon fünf Tore gemacht hat, ja, dann auch einfach so spielt, wie er spielt, ist das natürlich dann einer, den wirst du nicht ewig halten können. Aber dann hast du zumindest so einen guten Deal gemacht, wenn alles gut läuft, drücken wir die Daumen, dass du halt ein paar Millionen für den Jungen bekommst. Und das ist ja dann für einen nicht ganz so groß aufgestellten Verein wie den Club auch immer das, wo du halt schauen musst, ne, dass du da dann das beste Geschäft machst, wenn du weißt, du kannst so einen Jungen nicht ewig halten. Ja, das sind so relativ viele Sachen, die mir eigentlich gerade Mut machen. Also das ist jetzt der klassische Club-Fan-Optimismus, der da bei mir zu hören ist. Also negativ bin ich gerade gar nicht tatsächlich. Nee, es ist nie alles perfekt, aber der Weg ist so ein bisschen der, der stimmt. Für meine Verhältnisse gerade, wie ich das als Fan jetzt einordnen würde.
Ach, das ist auch so wohltuend, das mal zu hören. Ich habe schon so oft über den Club hier gesprochen und habe ja auch wirklich viele Bezüge dazu. Und mal hier so viel Positives zu hören und zu hoffen, dass es irgendwie den neuen Günduan gibt mit Usun.
Also ich bin natürlich auch, ich meine jetzt der ein oder andere kennt mich vielleicht oder kennt mich auch nicht, aber ich bin generell auch eher ein Positiver. Also es muss schon was passieren, dass ich negativ bin. Aber jetzt gerade finde ich, kann man das durchaus auch mal sein. Also wir dürfen jetzt nicht von Aufstieg träumen und dass das jetzt ein Selbstläufer wird. Und man steht im Achtelfinale im Pokal und alles gut. Und das ist ein guter Weg im Moment. Aber da glaube ich, ist gerade mit Christian Fjell schon auch der richtige Mann im Moment da, der das sehr schnell einfängt und der sagt, wir müssen unseren Klassenerhalt frühzeitig sichern und wir wollen 40 Punkte. Und das ist das Thema. Und das ist immer gut zu hören, wenn du auch so jemanden dann einfach da sehr prominent hast.
Aber wie würdest du das denn einschätzen? Ist das jetzt ein goldener Jahrgang, der da beim Club aus dem Nachwuchs hochgekommen ist? Oder hat es auch einfach damit zu tun? Also klar, Ozone ragt natürlich heraus. Aber gleichzeitig fällt ja auch auf, dass der ehemalige Jugendtrainer jetzt der Cheftrainer geworden ist.
Ich glaube tatsächlich schon, dass es ein Stück weit zusammenhängt. Einfach weil Christian Pfehl die Jungs kennt und ein guter Ansprechpartner ist, weil er weiß, wie er mit dem einen oder anderen umgehen muss. Also gerade in Jan Uzon war ja dann auch mal, nachdem dieses Hoch sehr, sehr hoch war, zwei, drei Spiele nicht in der Startelf. Und ich glaube, das war zum Beispiel auch eine ganz bewusste Entscheidung von einem Christian Pfehl zu sagen, hey, der muss auch mal durchatmen, der ist jetzt sehr im Rampenlicht gewesen. Dann kommen natürlich auch die Anfragen von Medien. Dann wirst du plötzlich gehypt. Also Michi sagt ja schon, der neue Messi, ich weiß auch nicht, wie oft ich bei den Kollegen von Sky im Kommentar gehört habe. Das ist der nächste Max Morlock. Also wirklich, die Vergleiche waren ja schon nach zwei, drei Spielen auf einem Niveau, wo man sich schon denkt, okay, was macht das denn mit so einem 17-Jährigen? Guck doch mal, dass du den auf dem Boden behältst. Und ich glaube, das ist was, was Christian Pfehl ganz gut kann und was aber auch die Mannschaft, glaube ich, insgesamt ganz gut im Griff hat, weil man eben noch Leute wie einen Enrico Valentini im Team hat, der so lange dabei ist, der jetzt nicht mehr Stammspieler, aber trotzdem Kapitän ist, der, glaube ich, dann sehr, sehr wichtiger Ansprechpartner gerade auch für die jüngeren Spieler ist, auch ein Chris Martenia. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen was, was man immer wieder hört. Die junge Truppe, die es da gerade so gibt, holt sich dann schon auch den Rat an der einen oder anderen Stelle und bekommt den Support. Und ich glaube, das ist gerade so eine Kombination, die einfach ganz gut passt. Du hast da ein paar gute Jungs, die jetzt aus der U-Mannschaft kommen. Du hast den Trainer, der auch auf die jüngeren Spieler setzen will, der da die Chancen einräumt. Wir haben jetzt keine 5, 6 Leihspieler gerade irgendwie im Kader. Das finde ich jetzt auch nochmal eine andere Situation, wo du dann sagst, ok, du gehst jetzt einfach den Weg und schenkst den Jungs das Vertrauen. Und ich glaube, das muss halt im Endeffekt auch der Weg sein, wenn du ein Verein bist wie der Klub, dass du nicht die Millionen in jedem Transferfenster rausballern kannst, dass du dir deine Jungs hochziehen musst. Und das wird gerade, finde ich, sehr, sehr gut gemacht. Und stimmt mich dann doch optimistisch, ja.
Das ist wirklich absolut faszinierend zu hören. Und jetzt habe ich ja aber mit Michi jemanden noch, der auch beruflich ja auch viel mit dem Klub zu tun hat. Also wenn ich euch beiden zuzuhöre, dann könnte es ja bei beiden sein, dass sie aufsteigen. Also du hast zwar vorhin schon die Euphorie gebremst, Michi, und so weiter, und Lisa hat auch schon gesagt, es kommt vielleicht noch zu früh, aber im Grunde hat sie ja gesagt, nächstes Jahr, dann ist es safe.
Das fände ich super nächstes Jahr, da wäre ich dabei.
Da bist du wahrscheinlich nicht so alleine, Lisa. Da lehne ich mich jetzt mal weit aus dem Fenster. Aber Michi, nehmt ihr denn das als Berichterstattender auch so wahr? Ich meine, du arbeitest jetzt ja für ein Nürnberger Medium, dass es da eine gewisse Euphorie oder einen sehr großen Optimismus gibt?
Ich habe ja jeden Tag eigentlich mit den Clubkollegen bei uns zu tun. Und da war diese Bissle Anspielung auf diesen Messi-Usun-Vergleich. Es gibt einen Kollegen, ich nenne ihn nicht namentlich, er war aber auch schon mal im Rasenfunk, der sehr hyped ist von Can Usun. Ich erinnere mich daran, er hat sehr früh gesagt, Can Usun muss bei ihm, wenn er Trainer wäre, würde er immer spielen. Da waren auch Diskussionen, ob Can Usun spielen soll. Und er hat recht behalten. Ich finde auch, Can Usun sollte immer spielen. Ich fand das auch immer noch, das ist ja überhaupt nicht despektierlich gemeint. Klar, der wird sehr gehypt, aber ich finde es erstaunlich, wie cool der Junge mit 17 Jahren mit diesem Druck umgeht. Ich habe vorhin das Derby angesprochen, so einen Spieler in Reihen zu haben. Es macht ja auch Spaß, so jemandem einfach zuzuschauen. Ich bin dafür bekannt, dass ich der größte Sympathisant des 1. FC Nürnbergs bin. Aber die Bewegungen von solchen Spielern, da sieht man einfach, das ist kein typischer 2. Liga-Spieler. Das ist halt einfach jemand, der mindestens mal in der Bundesliga spielt. Wenn er seinen Weg weiterhin geht, scheint er sehr klug im Kopf zu sein. Da kommt natürlich auch viel auf der Beratung, dass die Familie dann da weiterhin dabei bleibt. Aber so ein Spieler, klar, ich bin auch in letzter Zeit begeistert, dass der Klub so viele Jugendspieler nach oben bringt, weil ich finde, der Klub hat seit vielen Jahren extrem gute Jugendarbeit. Das war, glaube ich, ein guter Schritt mit Christian Fjell, der jemand so installiert, der auch jemanden, der da Spieler auch einbauen will. Das war im Klub nicht immer so, dass die Trainer auch einbauen wollten, diese Spieler. Die sind dann oft gegangen. Vielleicht waren sie auch manchmal nicht gut genug. Es gab auch beim Klub gewickelt jedes Jahr einen Stürmer, der U23, der immer 15 Tore schießt. Und jeder denkt, das ist der nächste Starspieler.
Endlich haben wir den Torjäger, den man seit so vielen Jahren sucht.
Aber man sieht ihn dann gar nicht in der ersten Mannschaft. So weit kommt es doch gar nicht.
Jermain, die Schalke, erinnere ich mich noch. Der hat im Derby im Winter gespielt und spielt jetzt als Jermain, die Schalke bei Dortmund 2. Aber ich finde schon, dass es da eine große, also der Club-Fan und allgemein das Umfeld des 1. FC Nürnberg neigt jetzt schon zu großem Optimismus, finde ich. Neigt aber auch zu großem Pessimismus, wenn es mal schlecht läuft. Und jetzt gerade gönne ich allen diesen Optimismus. Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass der Club aufsteigen wird dieses Jahr. Genau so wenig wie die Spielverhandlungen. Dafür finde ich zum Beispiel den FC St. Pauli schon mal viel zu stark. Also einen Aufstiegsplatz würde ich jetzt schon mal typen, ist weg.
Ja, da wird an allen Ecken dieses Calls hier genickt. Das kann ich mal übersetzen für alle Podcast-Hörenden. Und dennoch würde ich festhalten, wir haben noch nie so euphorisch über den Tabellenelfen der 2. Liga gesprochen. Aber wir hatten ja auch noch nie den besten Tabellenelfen aller Zeiten. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal, aller Zeiten hier.
Also bisher ist das in der Statistik so, Max. Wer weiß, was noch kommt, aber bislang halten wir fest, ist ja auch mal schön, über den Club und positiv drüber zu sprechen. Ich habe noch gelacht, die letzte Folge, 2. Liga, von eurem Ligaturformat, der Kommentar, zu wenig Club. Also ich glaube, da kann sich heute keiner beschweren.
Ja, absolut. Das habe ich mir auch zur Harzen genommen. Lieber Kommentator, du hattest ja völlig recht. Der Club stand schon lange hier auf der Liste. Ja, also ich kann dir aber sagen, was kommt. Paderborn kommt nämlich auswärts und dann bin ich mal gespannt. Entweder ist man 3. oder dann 12. oder 11. Natürlich hat Paderborn 18 Punkte. Im Grunde haben sie doch alle 18 Punkte da in der 2. Liga aktuell. Alle außer der KSC. Und damit sind wir bei Jörn gelandet. Der KSC hat 12 Punkte, ist damit Tabellen 16. Man hat den Anschluss zu einer Riege an Clubs, die 13 Punkte haben. Also wir müssen jetzt nicht klar vom Abstieg sprechen. Aber Jörn, es ist jetzt auch nicht das, was man sich erhofft hatte beim KSC. Denn bei allem, was KSC-Fans schon durchgemacht haben, hatte ich zumindest schon den Eindruck, dass das neue Stadion jetzt endlich fertig ist. Man hatte dieses Testspiel gegen Liverpool, wo man glaube ich knapp verloren hat, 2 zu 3 oder irgendwie so. Aber das war quasi die offizielle Stadioneröffnung. Und ich hatte schon das Gefühl, dass es so eine Art Aufbruchsstimmung beim KSC gab. Kenne ich den KSC sehr schlecht oder war dem auch so? Und man hat die sich dann sehr schnell durch ein Ausscheiden bei Saarbrücken, was wirklich peinlich ist. Das ist ja sonst niemandem passiert, da 1 zu 2 zu verlieren in dem Pokal. Hat man sich dadurch kaputt gemacht?
Ja, ich glaube, das ist die gute Frage, die man sich so beantworten muss. Also es gibt auch Leute in meinem Umfeld, die sind schon reichlich nervös, sage ich mal. Ich glaube, eine gewisse Euphorie im Umfeld kann man nicht bestreiten. Aber ich bin deshalb noch relativ entspannt, weil ich mich tatsächlich im Sommer gefragt habe, woher kommt diese Euphorie eigentlich? Ja, Wildpark ist fertig, richtig. Das Spiel gegen Liverpool, 2 zu 4 verloren, war aber auch ein super Spiel. Und vor allem unsere kleine Märchen-Story. Da Lars zurück nach 15 Jahren zu seinem Jugendverein und haut erstmal ein Traumtor gegen Liverpool rein. Dann gewinnt man relativ souverän in Osnabrück mit 3-2. Holt dann gegen HSV auch ein gutes Unentschieden, 2-2. Was die Euphorie sicherlich gefördert hat. Und dann kommt natürlich, wie du angesprochen hast, dieses unverzeihliche Ausscheiden im Pokal gegen Osnabrück. Und dann ging es eigentlich so los. Ich persönlich habe uns eher auf 8-12 geschätzt vor der Saison, um ehrlich zu sein. Auch aufgrund des Umfeldes und der Umstände, die dann zu einem Kader geführt haben, der meiner Meinung nach ein Kader ist, der für eine absolute Übergangs-Saison spricht. Wie man das so schön sagt immer. Zu alt, nicht tief genug besetzt beispielsweise. In manchen Mannschaftsteilen überragend gut. Überdurchschnittlich gut für die 2. Liga. Aber in manchen Mannschaftsteilen gerade das Gegenteil. Beziehungsweise langsam alternd und nicht mehr auf dem Peak der eigenen Leistung sein. Und dementsprechend wundert es mich jetzt Platz 16 schon grundsätzlich. Weil wir auch von den Punkten her ein bisschen underperformed haben, würde ich sagen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz bin ich immer noch relativ optimistisch aufgrund der Mannschaften, die sich da unten tummeln, dass wir dann doch die Stärkste sind da perspektivisch gesehen. Mir fallen auch, Michi hat es ja angesprochen, wir fallen so Fliegspiele ein gegen Fürth zum Beispiel. Da drehst du das Spiel in der ersten Halbzeit noch kurz vor Abpfiff. Und ich sage es mal so, Fürth wusste ja gar nicht mehr, was los ist, und dann muss man so ein Spiel in die Halbzeit bekommen. Stattdessen kriegen wir das 3-3. Fürth, Berndienst, rote Karte, kurz darauf, ich glaube, 3-4 Minuten später fällt durch eine Ecke das Gegentor. Und davon hat sich die Mannschaft nicht mehr so richtig erholt. Und es ist leider Gottes ein paar Mal vorgekommen schon diese Saison. Also, wenn sie richtig 100% reingelegt haben, alle Prozent reingelegt haben, dann sind auch Spiele rausgekommen, wo am Ende was Zählbares rauskam. Ich habe vorhin auch noch mal geguckt wegen Expected Goals, weil es mich hier angesprochen hatte einmal, KSC ist tatsächlich liaweit auf Platz 5 bei Expected Goals mit 1,64. Und vorne ist einfach zu wenig Ertrag. Ich habe auch noch mal das Fürth-Spiel angeguckt, da hatten sie 1,82 Expected Goals und so weiter und so fort.
Sie haben ja drei gemacht.
Ja, sie haben drei gemacht.
Das heißt, sie hätten deutlich verlieren müssen. Danke, dass wir es endlich klargestellt haben.
Fürth-Spiel ist vielleicht ein falsches Beispiel, aber gegen Kiel, wo sie nur zwei verlieren, war es ähnlich. Ich glaube, es liegt aktuell vor allem an dem Sommer, wo wir dann an den nicht sportlichen Themen direkt dran sind, würde ich sagen.
Würde ich aber gerne noch ganz kurz beim Sport bleiben, bevor wir dann wieder Haus auf Karlsruhe starten können. Wenn du schon sagst, manche Mannschaftsteile sehr gut aufgestellt, manche Mannschaftsteile schon ein bisschen zu alt, wo ich mir gleich dachte, was hat er denn jetzt gegen Lars Stindl? Ich dachte, es ist die Mädchengeschichte, dass er heimkommt, aber vielleicht hast du ihn ja gar nicht gemeint. Deswegen muss ich dich jetzt fragen, welche Mannschaftsteile meinst du denn? Wo ist denn der KSC gut aufgestellt?
Also der KSC ist gut aufgestellt. Also quasi im ersten Blick gewissermaßen im Mittelfeld. Da hat man Paul Nebel, Marvin Vanicek, Lars Stindl und Jerome Gondorf. Alles gestandene Spieler. Und gerade hatte ich vor kurzem mit Tim vom Millerntor noch drüber, gerade Vanicek ist in den letzten 5 Jahren der mit Abstand konstanteste Mittelfeldspieler in der 2. Liga. Also immer mindestens 15 Scorer-Punkte in den letzten 5 Jahren beispielsweise. Also das ist wirklich das Herzstück. Und Paul Nebel ist ein unfassbarer Spieler. Ich glaube, Paul Nebel ist der einzige Spieler in der 2. Bundesliga diese Saison, der es geschafft hat, Marcel Havel bei den gelaufenen Kilometern zu überholen. Paul Nebel ist am Millerntor 13,07 Kilometer gelaufen, Marcel Havel 13,02 Kilometer. Insgesamt beide Mannschaften 125 Kilometer am Millerntor. Also an der Intensität liegt es auch nicht. Zum einen muss man dann klar an Tor außen vorlassen. Da haben wir eher einen Gewinn gemacht, finde ich. Mit der Abgabe von Gerstbeck nach Berlin und dafür Trebes von Sandhausen bekommen. Super 2. Liga Torwart oder guter 2. Liga Torwart. Und jetzt kommen wir zur Abwehr. Da liegt der Hase im Teffer gewissermaßen mit den Außenverteidigern. Für rechts haben wir im Endeffekt Sebastian Jung mit 33 Jahren, der jetzt verletzt ist. Schon zweimal ausgewechselt werden muss in den letzten Spielen wegen muskulärer Probleme. Sein Backup ist Marco Tiede, der mittlerweile auch schon 31 ist und auch so ein bisschen den Zenit seiner 2. Liga-Karriere überstritten hat. Er ist trotzdem ein super Spieler, passt gut in den Kader. Auf der linken Seite hatten wir eigentlich nur den Philipp Heise, der 32 Jahre alt ist. Da ist aktuell als Backup David Herold da, als Leihgabe von Bayern. In der Innenverteidigung würde ich sagen, eher Zweitliga-Durchschnitt aktuell mit Bormuth und Marcel Franke, die leider eigentlich auch gar keinen richtigen Ersatzspieler haben. Also Marcel Beifuss, der wurde von St. Pauli geholt, fest ein junger Spieler. Der wurde aber ganz klar als Perspektivspieler geholt. Und der Rest ist aktuell verletzt. Und man hat es jetzt beim Auswärtsspiel in St. Pauli zum Beispiel oder bei St. Pauli gesehen, dass tatsächlich auf der KSC-Bank 5 Spieler saßen. Und man liefert ein richtig gutes Zweitligaspiel ab bis zur 65. Minute. Macht wirklich taktisch alles richtig. Also man macht das Zentrum dicht, zwingt St. Pauli zu Flügelverlagerungen, die dann auch nicht so präzise waren. Und ich denke mir noch im Stadion in der 65. Minute, ach krass, wir gewinnen ja heute, wenn es so weiter geht. Und dann bringt halt St. Pauli, das gehört ja bei St. Pauli auch zur Wahrheit dazu, einen luxemburgischen Nationalspieler und Simon Zoller. Und wir haben auf der Bank den jungen Innenverteidiger, die zwei Ü30 Außenverteidiger, den Burnic fürs Mittelfeld noch und einen Stürmer, den Budi Cifcivatse. Genau, und im Sturm hatten wir relativ viele Abgänge im Sommer, aber das waren so eigentlich Abgänge, die sich nicht durchsetzen konnten so richtig. Also die Spieler, die fest da waren. Mit dem Simone Rapp, der wollte unbedingt weg. Ich glaube, der hat sich mehr Einsatzzeiten versprochen. Dann Malik Badmatz aus der eigenen Jugend, war irgendwann auf dem Plateau, wurde zu Preußen Münster abgegeben, wo er 9 Tore geschossen hat. Aber wie gesagt, 2. Liga-Spieler, als Stammspieler würde ich ihn auch nicht so einordnen. Und vor allem, was wehgetan hat, war Leihspieler, Mittelkaufmann. Wer, das vergessen ja auch viele, in der letzten Saison, in der Hinterrunde noch gar keine Rolle gespielt hat, und den Christian Eichner hinbekommen hat. Das ist meine größte Hoffnung aktuell, dass die jungen Spieler, die wenigen jungen Spieler, die wir haben, also wir sind das Gegenteil von Fürth und von Nürnberg, ich glaube, wir hatten auch schon eine Startelf mit Ü31 dieses Jahr auf dem Feld, dass die jungen Spieler, das Eichner, die so hinbekommt, dass er halt auch wirklich nachhaltig, oder was heißt nachhaltig, dauerhaft beitragen können. Bestes Beispiel wäre Igor Matanovich, der jetzt seit zwei, drei Spielen voll da ist und ein Superspieler ist in allem, finde ich. Also Abschluss, Ball festmachen, hat leider jetzt gegen Paderborn eine riesen Chance vergeben. Aber das ist wichtig, dass wir nicht Lars Stindl als zweiten Stürmer aufbieten müssen wie in Magdeburg. Weil dessen Heimat ist mit 35 Jahren eher so auf der 10, dass er die Jungen schicken kann. Er hat ja immer noch einen starken Abschluss. Und wenn man den so einsetzen kann, ist er immer noch sehr wertvoll.
Okay, also jetzt hast du uns dann quasi erklärt, wo so die Baustellen im Kader liegen. Und auch schon eigentlich relativ gut, wie auch diese unterschiedlichen banklämütigen Ergebnisse zustande kommen. Und jetzt sagst du ja, das hat viel auch damit zu tun, wie eben strukturell der KSC aufgestellt ist oder personell quasi in der sportlichen Leitung und ja auch im Vorstand und so weiter und so fort. Was hat sich denn seit unserer letzten Folge, die ich natürlich verlinken werde, weil das können wir unmöglich wieder alles nacherzählen. Und ehrlicherweise, ich habe auch das Board, was ich mir damals gemacht habe, mit den ganzen roten Fäden und so weiter, das habe ich leider letzte Woche entsorgt. Deswegen geht das nicht mehr. Das waren natürlich aber blaue Fäden, fällt mir gerade ein. Was hat sich denn seitdem getan?
Na gut, getan hat sich, da muss man eben ein bisschen in den Sommer zurückgehen. Getan hat sich, du hattest mir, glaube ich, auch geschrieben mit dieser Struktur im sportlichen Bereich. Haben Sie sich dann im Juni entschieden, dass quasi Michael Becker der eigentliche kaufmännische Chefsführer jetzt der Gesamtgeschäftsführer wird? Und dass darunter nur noch drei Bereichsleiter sind. Der Bereichsleiter Scouting, Entwicklung, Analyse, der Bereichsleiter Akademie, sprich NLZ, und eben der Bereichsleiter Profis. Und die zwei Stellen, Scouting und NLZ, wurden schnell besetzt. Unter anderem mit dem Vater von Michael Becker, also quasi Edde Becker, berichtete zu seinem Sohn. Und Michael Bischoff, der hat Scouting gemacht, und Bereichsleitung Profis blieb erst mal umbesetzt bis Ende August. Da haben sie sich dann für Sebastian Freis entschieden, der mehr oder weniger aus seinem eigenen Stall kam. Und, nee, nicht mehr oder weniger. Er kommt aus dem eigenen Stall, de facto. Und war Teil der sogenannten Task Force. Weil der KSC nach dem Rausschmiss von Oliver Kreuzer eine Task Force eingesetzt hat, die sich eben um Transfers gekümmert hat. Dementsprechend, ja.
Also der KSC hat eine Task Force gebildet. Der KSC hat sich einfallen lassen, dass man einen Chef hat und darunter drei Bereichsleiter. Ist der KSC die Vereinsinkarnation des DFB? Oder ist es nicht ganz so schlimm?
Na ja, man wird sehen, wie am Ende der Output ist, glaube ich. Ich finde halt lustig, dass diese Organisation, und das wurde irgendwie auch in der Presse gar nicht so richtig aufgegriffen, meiner Meinung nach, dass man das mal so zumindest reflektiert. Dass quasi der geschäftsführer, kaufmännische Geschäftsführer und der sportliche Geschäftsführer Ende März in eine Sitzung gehen. Es bleibt der kaufmännische Geschäftsführer übrig und der ist plötzlich botzt von allen. Dieser Vorgang ist so ein bisschen, habe ich irgendwie ein Störgefühl, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Am Ende des Tages sind sie wohl mit Carsten Rothenbach vom FC St. Pauli, der im NLZ tätig ist, Team Manager der U23, sind sie wohl in weiten Verhandlungen. Die Presse steckt das durch. Carsten Rothenbach sagt offensichtlich ab, also so war es der Presse zu entnehmen. Der KSC präsentiert einen Tag später diese Neustrukturierung. Die lag ja in der Schublade. Offensichtlich war der Druck so groß, dass sie sagen müssen, okay, stimmt. Ist halt so. So wie ich Sportdirektoren kennengelernt habe in den letzten Jahren, frage ich mich, wie einfach ist es, jemanden zu finden, der eine Bereichsleitung übernimmt, der nicht Chef ist?
Ja, und vor allem der an jemanden berichtet, der keinen sportlichen Fokus hat. Das ist ja auch noch so was, was häufig auf dieser Position eine Rolle spielt.
Und am Ende kommt man halt dann mit der Hauslösung raus, die wahrscheinlich, weil das macht A und B, weil es ja auch finanzierbar ist. Du hattest es gerade schon angesprochen, dann sind wir nämlich beim Thema gewissermaßen. Nachdem Sebastian Freis aus dieser Taskforce zum BL Sport ernannt wurde, oder BL Profis, Bereichsleiter Profis, hat ein weiteres Mitglied der Taskforce, der technische Leitersport, Netschad Aigün, wurde eben verkündet auf der Homepage, dass der geht. Und er hat unter anderem im Zitat gesagt, es war eine positive und konstruktive Zusammenarbeit. Einen Monat später gibt Netschad Aigün, der nicht geschafft, das ist ja falsch, einvernehmlich wurde der Vertrag aufgelöst offiziell, gibt der Badischen Neuesten Nachrichten ein längeres Interview, wo er gerade das anspricht. Also, dass jetzt in den letzten Monaten der wirtschaftliche Leiter zu viel Macht hatte, im Endeffekt hat er über Transfers entschieden und so weiter und so fort. Also im Endeffekt, es ist immer schwer, Leute wollen sich ja dann quasi positionieren in der Presse, deshalb weiß man ja nie, was dahinter steckt, sage ich mal, aber dass es sehr, sehr grummelt im Verein, dafür war dieses Interview quasi das beste Beispiel. Was macht der KSC? Der KSC stellt sich hin und zerlegt das Interview von Netschad Aigün in seine Einzelteile auf der Homepage mit einer Stellungnahme. Wo ich mir denke, Leute, müsst ihr über dieses Stöckchen springen. Also ehrlich, so viel erzählt er ja nicht.
Aber Jörn, da kennst du dich wahrscheinlich einfach zu schlecht mit Pressearbeit aus. Ach nee, Moment. Ach so. Du hast genau das mal beruflich gemacht beim FC St. Pauli. Dann weiß ich jetzt auch nichts.
Außerdem hättest du es ja auch an der PK zerlegen können. Eben. Wäre noch viel schlimmer gewesen.
Naja, also im Endeffekt dröselt der KSC es so auf, was denn jetzt falsch war und stellt klar, was da jetzt falsch war, was er da so und so rausschmeißer, der Klassiker. Keiner steht über dem KSC. Wer meldet sich als nächstes? Der Vizepräsident. Vizepräsident vom KSC war in diesem Fall der Müller. Martin Müller stellt sich, der quasi mit Günter Pilarski, als Oliver Kreuzer entlassen wurde im Frühjahr, sehr öffentlichkeitswirksam klargemacht hat, dass diese Entscheidung richtig doof war, weil die Entscheidung auch 3 zu 2 fiel. Der Beirat, der quasi Geschäftsführer ist, besteht beim KSC immer aus Präsidium, Vizepräsidenten und 2 Beisitzern. Und lustigerweise sind die Vizepräsidenten die, die für eine Weiterbeschäftigung von Kreuzer gestimmt hatten eigentlich. Auf jeden Fall meldet sich Müller und sagt so suffisant in der Presse, naja, an dem, was Netschert Aigün gesagt hat und wo er Einblick hat, kann er eigentlich nichts Falsches entdecken. Der Karlsruher Sportclub reagiert erneut mit einem offenen Brief.
Das wird ja jetzt immer besser, Jörn. Also ich muss mir das jetzt auch gleich aufzeichnen, so wie Max das schon angeteasst hat.
Vor allem beim KSC weiß man nie, vielleicht sind wir immer noch erst im Juli.
Das ist jetzt quasi das, was ich angesprochen habe. Das Interview war quasi im Oktober und die Reaktion auf dieses Interview kam direkt so 13. oder 14.
Oktober rum.
Du hast mich ja immer up to date gehalten.
Deswegen, ja. Auch die Reaktion des Vizepräsidenten kam prompt und auch wiederum die Reaktion des Vereins kam prompt mit dem offenen Brief, wo im Endeffekt gesagt wird, da sind wir nämlich, was Michi auch meinte, dass der eingeschlagene Weg, also sprich diese Umstrukturierung, ist eben die Grundlage für die Wahrscheinlichkeit, den sportlichen und wirtschaftlichen Erfolg zu erhöhen. Und natürlich geht es nicht ohne Geburtsschmerzen, sage ich mal, ab. Und ja, man muss halt quasi zusammenhalten und man ist in einer schweren, sportlichen Situation usw. usf. so in die Richtung. Dieser Brief wird unterschrieben von über 30 KSC-Mitarbeitern, also auch leitende Angestellte, unter anderem von Präsidenten, von Aufsichtsrat usw. usf. Dieser Brief wird nur nicht unterschrieben von den beiden Vizepräsidenten.
Also 2 zu 30 wurde dieser Brief verabschiedet, sagen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Ja, genau. Mit dem Argument, die Formulierung in dem Brief ist, dass es eine umfangreiche Analyse gab, die eben zu dieser Reorganisation des sportlichen Gesamtbereichs geführt hat. Und da hat der Vizepräsident in der Presse dann wiederum gesagt, die gab es ja gar nicht.
Es ist ja wirklich wie beim BVB. Das ist ja wie beim Frauenteam.
Die gab es ja nicht, deshalb dementsprechend wollte er sich nicht identifizieren. Im Endeffekt hat er das Ding nur vorgelegt gekommen und sollte unterschreiben und das hat er überhaupt nicht eingesehen usw. Der Fan-Dachverband, die Supporters, die im Frühjahr noch gesagt haben, ja, man muss alles aus der Öffentlichkeit raushalten usw. hat dann wiederum eine Stellungnahme rausgegeben und gesagt, sie haben sichere Informationen, dass Vizepräsident Martin Müller interner an die Presse weitergeleitet hat. Und er hat dann wiederum über die Presse verlaubt werden lassen. Er sei völlig respektlos und amateurhaft und unprofessionell. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Am Ende ist es so, der Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende Grenke hat versucht, es zu löschen. Aktuell ist es auch gelöscht in dem Sinne. Die Mitgliederversammlung findet Anfang Dezember statt. Die wird übers Schicksal des Präsidiums entscheiden. Was vielleicht auch wichtig ist bei der Stellungnahme der Supporters, weil es wurde vermutet, dass der Vizepräsident eigene Ambitionen hat, Präsident zu werden. Die Supporters haben schon droppen lassen nach dem Motto, du gehst hier überhaupt kein Präsident, sondern wenn, dann wird hier die Vertrauensfrage gegen dich gestellt. Der Fan-Dachverband der Supporters ist mächtig. Das sind die meisten Leute auf der Mitgliederversammlung. Ich gehe davon aus, dass er eher das Vertrauen verlieren würde, als Präsident zu werden. Aber das ist eine persönliche Einschätzung. Das ist jetzt der Stand. Christian Eichner hat auch auf der Pressekonferenz nach Schalke, dass das Spiel 3-0 gewonnen wurde, verlautbaren lassen, dass er in dem Sinn stolz auf seine Mannschaft ist, dass er sich total auf Fußball konzentrieren konnte. Er hat durchblicken lassen, dass das die Situation beeinflusst. Jetzt sind wir da, wo wir sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob das mit der Unruhe im Umfeld so gut ist, trotz meines Optimismus.
Es ist bitter. Wir hätten jetzt genau die Zeit, die wir gesprochen haben, über das Fernprojekt Karlsruhe und das laufende Gerichtsverfahren. Das ist das viel, viel wichtigere Thema. Aber dazu gibt es auch andere Berichterstattung. Das kann man sich erlesen. Und wenn es da eine Entscheidung gibt, dann hoffe ich, dass ich es in den Rasenfunk heben kann. Aber wir haben ja schon im letzten Mal, als wir gesprochen haben, verlief das Gespräch genauso. Nämlich, dass tausend Namen flogen durch den Raum. Und immer waren es die Vizepräsidenten, waren sich uneinig mit dem Rest. Das waren Minderheitenentscheidungen. Jetzt musste er gehen, Oliver Kreuzer usw. Aber wenn du jetzt mal versuchen müsstest, was natürlich schwierig ist, weil du bist ja auch weit weg, auch wenn du ganz tief in der Materie drin bist. Aber wie würdest du das denn jetzt einordnen? Sind das hier Machtspiele? Geht es darum, dass es da unterschiedliche Wege gibt, die man beschreiten möchte? Sind das vielleicht auch einfach nur große Egos, die aufeinander preien? Also bei aller Vorsicht natürlich. Es ist schwierig, das von außen zu beurteilen. Aber was wäre denn dein vorläufiges Fazit, warum ist so viel Unruhe beim KSC, wo man doch eigentlich Grund dachte zu haben, dass man sich jetzt mal wieder aufs Sportliche konzentrieren kann und es jetzt vorangeht?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich würde sagen, es ist wirklich so eine Mixtur aus allem, was du angesprochen hast. Das sind auf jeden Fall Egos, das sind auf jeden Fall Machtspiele. Definitiv. Die ganzen 3 zu 2 Entscheidungen im Präsidium, da geht es vor allem um Macht, natürlich, definitiv. Und ich glaube, was man auch nicht unterschätzen darf, ist diese finanzielle Geschichte. Speziell der Vizepräsident Martin Müller hat durch eigenes Geld ca. 5 Mio. ermöglicht, dass der Vorhergutpräsident, der Merkel des deutschen Fußballs war, so ein Stück weit, wo gar nichts voran ging, Ingo Wellenreuter, dass der gehen musste. Und das hat er damals aber noch mit der Hilfe von den Fans gemacht, sondern den Supporters. Dementsprechend war es jetzt für die schwierig, sich von dem abzusetzen gewissermaßen. Und am Ende des Tages, das ist total schwierig, weil ich bin mir bei der neuen Struktur auch nicht sicher. Also ich persönlich hätte lieber einen ganz normalen Geschäftsführersport beispielsweise. Weil ob das so perspektivisch funktionieren kann, kann ich überhaupt nicht sagen. Ich kann nur sagen, dass Oliver Kreuzer im Endeffekt den Job erfüllt hat. Er hat die Klasse gehalten, immer. Rein vom Budget her sind wir genau da, wo wir gerade stehen ungefähr. Und dementsprechend ist es auf jeden Fall ein mutiger Schritt, den vor allem dann der Präsident eingeleitet hat. Also Holger Sigmund Schulze, indem er diese Abstimmung über Oliver Kreuzer forciert hat. Und mit den ganzen Konsequenzen. Und das Ergebnis, wenn man ehrlich ist, mindestens erst im nächsten Sommer sehen. Das meinte ich vorhin, man kann eigentlich die Transferbilanz von KSC überhaupt nicht beurteilen, richtig. Weil es von der Task Force, die so ein bisschen improvisiert hat, arbeiten müssen.
Genau, also soll man Sebastian Freis dafür kritisieren, dass er zwischen August und Ende August nichts mehr hinbekommen hat. Und der KD jetzt an manchen Stellen ein bisschen zu dünn ist. Er hat den natürlich vorher auch schon in der Task Force mitzusprechen. Aber ja, es ist, also auf mich wirkt das so, wie eine riesengroße vergebene Chance. Weil man eben, Stadion ist fertig, Lars Stindl kehrt zurück. Du hast einen Trainer, Christian Eichner, wir haben jetzt überhaupt nicht über Christian Eichner gesprochen, müssen wir nämlich auch gar nicht. Der ist nämlich super, der ist genau am richtigen Ort. Und letztlich hast du auch mit Sebastian Freis jemand, wo glaube ich ganz viele KSC-Fans sagen, ja super, gehen wir mit. Weil auch der ist am richtigen Ort und hat eben zumindest als Spieler eben noch, als ehemaliger Spieler einen positiven Leum. Und auf mich wirkt das so, als ob man durch dieses Ganze hin und her vielleicht eine Chance vergibt, die so schnell auch nicht wiederkommen könnte beim KSC. Ich meine, ich lasse mich gerne eines Besseren belehren, aber das ist so mein Außenblick, den ich habe auf Karlsruhe.
Also das zum einen oder hier zum Abschluss vielleicht, also was es auf jeden Fall geben muss in irgendeiner Form, ist ein reinigendes Gewitter bei dieser Mitgliederversammlung. Weil so wie es aktuell ist, kann es eigentlich nicht weitergehen. Weil die werden das immer wieder öffentlich austragen, über die Medien beispielsweise. Also entweder es verändert sich das Präsidium, entweder es tritt ein komplettes neues Präsidium an, was ich mir nicht vorstellen kann aktuell. Aber da muss auf jeden Fall was geschehen in irgendeiner Form. Weil wenn die permanent streiten, zieht man nicht an einem Strang und dann geht es ja auch nicht voran. Also das ist glaube ich das, was man auf jeden Fall festhalten kann. Es wird was passieren und es wird glaube ich spannend.
Was hast du gesagt, 9. Dezember ist die? Okay, also das markieren wir uns schon mal mal gucken. Vielleicht musst du dann noch mal kommen und dann bringe ich wieder mein Board mit und frische Stecknadeln und neues Garn. Und dann kannst du mir erzählen, was bei House of Karlsruhe in der Sonderstaffel passiert ist. Aber das gucken wir uns ganz in Ruhe an, so wie wir uns ja ganz in Ruhe eure drei Vereine angeguckt haben. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Das war total interessant zu hören, wie unterschiedlich und doch ähnlich manche sich hier waren. Nur mit dem KSC konnte niemand mithalten. Aber das ist vielleicht in dem Fall gar nicht so schlecht.
Vielleicht gibt es beim Club auch bald ein kleines House of Karlsruhe. Ich sag nur Raphael Schäfer, Aufsichtsrat. Da hätten wir auch ein paar nicht so krass sportliche Themen, Max. Aber das wollen wir doch heute nicht nur aufhören.
Also Raphael Schäfer möchte in den Aufsichtsrat, seh ich das richtig?
Ja, und er wird in den Aufsichtsrat kommen.
Und es gibt da auch ein paar Themen abseits des Sportlichen. Aber es ist schön, dass wir darüber gar nicht uns beschäftigt haben. Also finde ich super, dass das auch noch ein bisschen hin, bis es so weit kommt. Aber Michi ist im Bilde.
Okay, alles klar. Also ich weiß, dass das gewisse Leute hören. Ruft mich einfach an, erklärt mir das. Ich weiß, dass ihr die Segmente zum Club immer hört. Und dann hole ich mir da die Infos dann eben dann off-air und dann überlege ich, was ich davon wieder reinhole. Aber ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Lisa Höfer. Danke, dass du hier warst.
Danke, dass es geklappt hat, Max. Super viel Spaß gemacht. Zeit ist verflogen und gerne wieder.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall. Dann mit Raphael Schäfer im Aufsichtsrat, nach dem, was ich jetzt gerade gehört habe. Herzlichen Dank auch an Michael Fischer. Auch nochmal ganz besonders, ohne jetzt zu verraten. Aber das ist ein ganz spezieller Aufnahmetermin für dich. Danke, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr, sehr gerne. Und vielleicht bist du zur Schlusskonferenz im nächsten Jahr.
Ja, Schlusskonferenz gibt es ja nicht mehr. Aber ich weiß, glaube ich, was du damit andeuten möchtest. Es gibt die Rasenfunk-Bundesliga der Männer.
Für mich ist das immer noch die Schlusskonferenz.
Ich bin schon alt. Schlusskonferenz always in our heart. In meinem auch noch so ein bisschen, muss ich es sagen. Und ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Jörn Kreuzer. Niemand hatte mehr Notizzettel dabei mit dazu. Aber niemand hat sie auch so sehr gebraucht wie du. Weil das ist ja wirklich kompliziert. Danke dir, Jörn, dass du mit dabei warst.
Und ich hoffe, dass es nicht so ausufernd war.
Wir danken dir und die Hörerinnen und Hörer. Die werden uns das schon sagen. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörer, auf rasen.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Unter mitmachen.rasen.de könnt ihr Feedback geben. Und auf rasen.de findet ihr generell alle Sendungen, die wir so aufgenommen haben. Also Frauen-Bundesliga und Männer-Bundesliga haben wir ja gemacht. Borussia Dortmund Schwerpunkt gibt es. Copa Libertadores habe ich gestern aufgenommen. Und wenn alles gut geht, wird am Freitag oder Samstag noch ein Tribüngespräch erscheinen. Jaha, wir hören nicht auf zu senden. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund, macht's gut.
Ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.